es soll eigentlich der schönste tag im
leben werden die hochzeit doch wenn wir
mal ehrlich sind
leider geht die ehe nicht immer gut aus
und dann kommt es eben zur scheidung und
dann muss viel geregelt werden und es
bleiben auch oft viele fragen offen mir
ist jetzt die scheidungsanwältin sabine
meyer live zugeschaltet und wir hatten
unsere zuschauer und auch leser gebeten
fragen einzusehen und wir wollen direkt
mit der ersten frage starten
wir hatten ja schon mal gesprochen wie
ungerecht ich mich behandelt fühle als
alleine ziehen wo sich der vater um das
kind nicht kümmert und das seit jahren
und das auch konsequent in der junge
freunde kriegt es mit
und es regelmäßig entsetzt darüber wie
egal sein vater geworden ist denn
nachteilig jeden monat das kindergeld
mit ihm
er verdiente höheren vierstelligen
bereich weist mich mit monatlich um die
300 euro ab und die krönung als von
alledem während ich corona bedingt
meinen job aufgeben musste darf ich den
kinderbonus mit ihm kann jetzt kommen
sie ich freue mich auch ihre hilfe ja
formal sie haben die frage gehört was
sagen sie dazu
natürlich ist zunächst eine absolute
ungerechtigkeit dem kind gegenüber stich
gelassen wird darin nicht nur die fragen
ja in welchem umfang sondern natürlich
auch die kinder das ist ja sehr wichtig
für die entwicklung und zum anderen ist
es ja gerade hier allein erziehen wir in
der schwierigen phase eine enorme
herausforderung alles zu spenden ohne
unterstützung ausbildungstätigkeit
beschulung der kinder und betreuer
also ich kann die leute hier sehr freuen
wenn sie da alles unter einen hut
bringen muss aber ist es so dieser bonus
gezahlt
zusammen mit dem kindergeld wenn sich
der vater endlich aus der verantwortung
entzieht und zb überhaupt kein kind und
fahrrad leistet man muss dies auch nicht
aufgeteilt werden